somebody tweeted out last night i hope
that trevor lawrence girl look alike is
doing well wherever she makes yeah
all right the one that i said i saw or
somebody else well
they did a story oh they did yeah yeah
i told you i saw someone in the in the
parking lot and i was and i thought it
was a boy and i was like i want to get a
picture and say i saw trevor lawrence
and then the the boy got up and it was a
it was a girl
hello my name is bella i'm from atlanta
georgia but you may know me from
we are here at hartwell jackson airport
about to hop on a flight to jacksonville
to see how many people think i'm
actually trevor lawrence
two hours later
i've already gotten a couple of double
takes a couple of
confused stairs so we'll see how much
more we can get out of these
jacksonville folks
congratulations bro ladies and gentlemen
we got him
all right we are headed to the
jacksonville zoo to see some real-life
jaguars and
make it all official
that is where we need to be that is the
destination
do you know where the jaguars exhibit is
i'll go home you do not
i don't okay thank you anyway
do you know where the jackpot exhibit is
the jaguar
um so you leave here and you'll turn
right it'll be the next plaza on your
right-hand side
and the jaguars will be on the right
hand side of the perfect thank you
are you a fan of the jacksonville
jaguars i am
did you watch the drafts last night i
was over here all night
you see that trevor lawrence got drafted
oh no
this way
[Music]
buddy you're on my shirt
next we're heading to the st john's town
center
to see if we can go find my trevor
we jersey looking for the first ever
jaguar trevor lawrence jersey
hey excuse me real quick this guy we're
on a time crunch
we got to get him to the stadium do you
guys happen to have any
driving in trevor lawrence jerseys that
are no we haven't
haven't gotten one not yet did y'all not
they weren't are you serious
it's a nut
all right well look around get something
else i think you said you needed a
i think he needed a water bottle or
something like that they could probably
take this one down i don't think they'll
need this one anymore
my name's colby i've been a jags fan
i'd have to say my whole life since i'm
born and raised here
shane and i've been a jacks fan since
i was a kid what are you most excited
about with trevor coming in town
at least get it down field more than
gardner mitchum i love that he's a
quality guy
i'm ready for that energy to come back
and you can tell the entire city
that energy is already here past 10
years i've been dealing with
blaine gabbert blake portals
[Music]
i don't know we just we i think we've
got some really loyal fans and we're
ready for some success
and hey like open up that locker room
and open those doors
not trevor good you almost got me you
got me for like a second
first second almost we're almost over
i think it was a good try
you're not tall enough but i was like
okay
well yeah got a lot of double takes
today some of them were you know
not as fooled but i hope steve
jacksonville welcomes trevor with
such open arms they have welcomed me
they are awesome fans and go checks
you